the historical mind is like a stone
struck on a tuning fork it has a
duration and at any point in the
duration you can extract the whole thing
I mean we are caught inside the
historical octave something like that a
pythagorean idea that all time is
contained in the moment until all time
dies away and then I guess we are left
in eternity but this historical
experience is the sounding of a tone
that is incoherent unless the full
duration is allowed for you to express
itself that's why in spite of how things
may look very negative I think you know
when the full tone of the historical
octave is sounded it will all make sense
it would be harmonious and there will be
order this is the chaos at the end of
history every idea will be brought out
tried thrown away or pushed forward
refined there's a frantic effort to
understand because we can feel that
we're breaking through these envelopes
of accumulated awful
- ever more novel states of freedom and
becoming
[Music]
you
[Music]